so listen I want to start with uh and I
really mean this sincerely you guys did
such a great job with this movie like I
it's it's so good I know fans are gonna
love it
um but but I want to ask something uh I
just want to start with that so the
version I've seen it twice and both
times there's no credits there's no
after the credit scene uh and I'm just
curious if when the movie gets released
will you guys be including and after the
credit scene or is it something that you
thought about and it's not gonna happen
there's uh so if you see the movie in
the on the 16th or after you'll notice
that there's a there's a couple
surprises there
um that uh we wanted to leave for the
for the release of the movie uh just to
avoid any kind of uh possible leagues
and stuff so there's a couple more
surprises there thank you I am looking
forward to seeing uh anyway I'll leave
that there so one of the things is uh uh
I love talking about the editing room
because it's where it all you know comes
together so can you talk about how the
film changed in the editing room and
maybe ways you guys weren't expecting
yeah of course there's uh well the first
thing is uh I like to shoot a lot and I
like to have uh options and uh and
depending on the actors I'm working with
we we have more or less material in the
case of my work with Ezra we had an
impossibly uh a long list of options
because uh uh uh Ezra is a phenomenal
actor who gives you a lot
and uh yeah we did a lot of improvising
that lead to the scenes to be longer
than expected and ended up with a
four-hour movie basically and yeah
that's the first uh answer the first
part of the answer is yeah there's
there's a lot of shape reshaping in the
movie in terms of making it uh uh
shorter basically uh but of course the
editing process is the real is the is a
place where uh things really take shape
you know like uh one thing is to have a
script and be in love with a script but
then production and the execution takes
you to a different place where there's a
lot of new things to consider and the
edit room is we're all all comes you
know comes to to to fall into place uh
and that requires a lot of work I wish
sometimes I wish I had uh you know a
time traveling machine to uh jump from
day one of edit to
six months of of the edit to see where
the ends but and to you know to
basically like when like not waste all
of that time trying things but the truth
is that it's a process that you have to
go through and it's a trial and error
and a lot of a lot of different versions
yeah I just I just want to say that uh I
would love to see some of those deleted
scenes so I will hopefully they'll be
eventually on the Blu-ray but I'm
curious for the two of you what would
have happened if Michael Keaton had
actually said no we wouldn't have made
this movie we wouldn't have been able to
make this this movie
um as it is and you know we we made it
clear to to him the first time we sat
um with him for lunch
um
if he had said no
um it would have been a completely
different story in the Multiverse
there's probably a version of this movie
without Michael Keaton
but we were not attached somewhere in
the Multiverse totally
um the third act has a lot of cool
surprises for fans of DC you know uh
Flash Superman uh was there anything
that you wanted to include that you
actually couldn't do to any sort of like
lawyers saying yeah that's not happening
no they're uh we we had a yes on
absolutely everybody we reached out to
the issue was time we wanted to give
each of the these cameos you know time
for people to you know have the time to
enjoy them
um so we had to cut down the list uh
which was very long
um but everybody we we approached their
Estates
um and you know the the living people
still
um they were they were game because they
understood what we wanted to do which
was to honor you know the legacy of DC
no completely what was actually for the
two of you
um what was actually the biggest
argument you guys had while making this
and who ended up winning no I think the
argument happens every day after you
know when the shoot comes to an end and
I want to keep shooting and Barbie's
looking at the clock and it's like we
don't we can't go into overtime which is
like a you know a historical problem and
not not only you know in our working
relationship but in all movies of
History the director wanting to do more
and and producer looking into the clock
so that's uh that's our our main uh
matter of of our humans it's it's boring
but um that's the way it is you know
Andy loves shooting more than anything
and also he does not have an internal
clock so he could the man could shoot
for 24 hours and go what what I don't
have it yet I don't have it uh so I
gotta tell him you have it and we gotta
go home uh I have to already wrap um if
you guys ever have the time I would love
to do a spoiler conversation talking
about some specifics please let me know
where and when and I will be there on
that note I really hope the film is a
huge huge hit for you guys thank you so
much